vous cherchez un médecin je suis médecin
j'aurais dû mourir il ya des années
dans le monde d'autres personnes
souffrent de la même maladie que moi
je suis là pour trouver un traitement ou
devons repousser les limites prendre de
risques
[Musique]
si vous voulez fuir c'est maintenant
docteur michael mais en plus vous avez
disparu pendant deux mois
un seuil
et puis on vous a retrouvé sur un cargo
échoué au large de l'ong island
qu'est ce que vous vous êtes faits
docteurs j'aimerais bien le savoir
j'ai des mourants et aujourd'hui je suis
plus vivant que jamais ça a marché pas
exactement je suis plus fort plus rapide
et j'ai comme un sonar de chauves souris
ce que j'ai d'autres capacités
[Musique]
il ya des limites il y en a forcément
quelque chose en moi
on pousse à chasser
et à consommer du sang mike hayes
olli rehn
peux-tu le contrôler
j'en sais rien
la moitié de la ville de votre peau
la dernière fois qu'on a vu un truc
aussi énorme c'était à san francisco
l'autre moitié vous contrôlez et le cas
michael pourquoi récents contacts que
les
n'importe quoi pour sauver des vies
j'ignore dont je suis capable
vous sauver les gens ne les tuez pas
[Musique]
tu venu guérir le monde
ou le détruire
t'es qui toi plutôt suis fait non je
plaisante docteur michael morbius à ton
service